[Music]
and so we found a video uh about
mortgages and we get a lot of hate for
our take on mortgages that you shouldn't
have one
it's a hot take that you should pay your
mortgage off because then you can really
live and give like no one else and build
wealth so let's watch this video and
i'll let you know my thoughts after
paying off your mortgage early isn't
always a great idea let me show you why
let's say that you have a three hundred
thousand dollar mortgage at a four
percent interest rate for thirty years
your payment is fourteen hundred dollars
you have an extra thousand dollars that
you can use to either pay off your
mortgage faster or invest let's look at
what happens in both cases if you use
your thousand dollars to pay off your
mortgage faster you'll pay off your
mortgage in 13 years and save 120k worth
of interest now start investing all of
that 2 400. 17 years later you'll have a
million dollars assuming an average 8
return now let's look at if you invest a
thousand dollars instead of paying off
your mortgage over the same 30 years
you'll pay 128 000 more in interest but
you'll have 1.4 million dollars in
investments paying off your mortgage
early would cost you 300 000 in total
wealth that's a lot of money sure you've
saved a bid on interest but you lost
money in the long run that's why it's so
important that you understand the way
personal finance actually works that way
you can crunch the numbers and choose
the path that makes the most financial
sense for you
oh so that's how personal finance
actually works
oh my goodness well if i had known that
i would have gotten to way more debt
because apparently you can make millions
by going into debt and staying in debt
okay
a lot of numbers were thrown out there
you can you can ignore the numbers for
now it's too much to keep in your brain
i tried to write some of it down it's
just too much but here's the deal uh as
a guy who paid off his house and some
people have said well that was a dumb
thing to do you should have invested the
money
listen it's hard enough for me to sleep
at night with everything going on in the
world but i sleep a whole lot better
knowing my home is paid for and i don't
owe anyone anything and here's the thing
people come at us and go well
you still have taxes and insurance so
you'll always have payments
you must be real fun at parties if
that's how you think and talk to people
so when it comes to the mortgage you're
right on paper you can do better if life
works out perfectly for you and you
magically have an extra thousand dollars
sitting around which news alert most
americans don't because they're broke
then yes on paper if it works out
perfectly and you get your exact return
every single year
and you get that exact mortgage scenario
sure you could end up with a few hundred
grand more
but the truth is
99.9 of americans aren't doing that will
not do that can't do that they don't
have extra money lying around and if you
think that if i did have extra money it
would all go towards investing because
i'm such an astute investor
you're also wrong because we know
lifestyle creep happens life happens a
vacation pops up a wedding pops up a
funeral life just happens hvac goes out
and so what happens is the people that
do that generally don't have an
emergency fund don't have extra money
and if they do they're probably hanging
out in reddit threads you know talking
about how much dave doesn't know about
personal finance which is totally fine
you are entitled to your opinion it is a
free country and you're entitled to have
uh to be wrong
that's part of freedom so to that point
here's what i'll say that video is
clearly geared towards younger people
which frustrates me because young people
in their 20s are starting to fall for
these traps and they're starting to
believe that debt is a tool to be
leveraged and you can create so much
wealth by leveraging debt
and so to that i say what if we didn't
have payments
and we invested the money what would
that turn into
how much life could we live in the
meantime before retirement before we
have 1.4 million dollars there's a lot
of life in between isn't there
we want to raise families we want to
send our kids to college debt-free we
want to go on amazing vacations we want
to give generously and what i have found
is that payments in your life hold you
back from doing all that in the meantime
over the next 30 years of your working
life
and so that is why i advocate for paying
off your mortgage early and we've
debunked many times the idea of the oh
you guys should hang on to your mortgage
for the tax deduction no we debunk this
all the time at our live events and
financial peace university you're
trading a dollar for a quarter if you're
keeping your mortgage around for the tax
deduction
because you want to pay your lender ten
thousand dollars instead of sending the
irs 2500 that's just bad math
so
all that to say uh please stop making
videos that are hurting young people i
want them to win financially i want them
to live a debt-free life not only
because of the financial side but the
psychological side the spiritual side
we're seeing so much anxiety and
depression with these younger
generations and a huge part of that
is because of money fears
money problems money issues and so i
think if we can get rid of that aspect
we can then focus on other things we can
be more self-less focus on others more
find opportunities where we can help
others because we're not so focused and
dialed in on our own money problems
so that's my encouragement to you guys
uh take it as you will that's tick tock
for you